[Applaus]
[Musik]
mein erster Eindruck war ja fantastisch
genau wie erwartet
ich dachte nur mein Gott ist er groß ja
das hast du mir gesagt
für mich zusammen
als Monika Peter artermann vor 14 Jahren
auf die Götterinsel Bali auswanderte war
sie überzeugt dass Single doch dann
lernte sie Deva kennen und alles kam
ganz anders
zwei Länder eine liebe das ist hin und
weg
[Musik]
und ich fühle mich einfach extrem wohl
wo Arbeit
ja eigentlich
meine Frau zum ersten Mal gesehen habe
war ich nervös
was konnte ich tun ich sprach nicht gut
englisch aber ich bleib dran langsam und
behutsam nur lächeln
so war das
nein nein nein nein nein
das Paar lebt im Süden Balis Monika ist
58 die war 38 Jahre alt
[Musik]
die beiden Hunde Lucky uns Bike sind ihr
ein und alles und halten Sie auf Trab
[Musik]
gut
es poule
Monika und Deva haben die Hunde gerettet
und adoptiert
es gibt Lappen im Haus es geht auch
extrem viel schöner
Name
sehr sehr gerne
der Tag beginnt um halb sechs Uhr
morgens dann ist es noch angenehm kühl
für das gemeinsame Frühstück nehmen Sie
sich Zeit dass ich mich absolut
lieblingsfruchtung
und einfach lecker
die Schweiz ist das alles ganz anders
hat aber auch schon als Personal Trainer
und Bodyguard gearbeitet sein Hobby ist
Bodybuilding
Monika ist selbstständig und als
interior Designerin tätig
die letzten Jahre haben die beiden in
der Schweiz verbracht darum versteht
Diva etwas Schweizerdeutsch
aber es mischt sich immer wieder
schweizerdeutscherinnen
aber es gefällt mir gut
ja
tätig sie und tätig irgendwie
sagte bei einem Wettkampf in Rumänien
Uroma der schönste Eiskunstläufer er
heißt Jamal Ottmann er ist Schweizer und
ja er gefiel mir er sieht zwar nicht
sehr schweizerisch aus aber es stimmt er
ist schön
[Musik]
Montreal seit acht Jahren ist die
kanadische Stadt das Zuhause von Jamal
und Roma
[Musik]
Jamal Ottmann wuchs in Münchenbuchsee
auf seine Mutter ist Schweizerin sein
Vater stammt aus Malaysia fünf Jahre
lebte er in Asien bevor er hierher zog
hallo
gehört zu den international
erfolgreichsten eiskunstlauf-trainern
die beiden sind seit zehn Jahren ein
Paar
[Musik]
sehr gut
als Roman Jamal traf war er hin und weg
insgeheim ja Baby ja das war wohl so
aber ich wollte es nicht zeigen
ich bin stolz und ich glaube eher auch
aber Urlaub natürlich gab es da was wir
wollten uns auch schnell Wiedersehen
damals arbeitete Jamal als Nationalcoach
in Malaysia und Singapur
zuvor war er Profi Eiskunstläufer nahm
an Olympischen Spielen und
Weltmeisterschaften teilen
dem Gesicht
[Musik]
[Applaus]
Operation vier Operationen
und für mich Sicherheit wenn wir
studieren nächste Karriere
glaubst du die Chance ist groß der
Schale gegen Graz dabei ist wieso weil
es so gesagt hat der 37-Jährige
kommentiert noch immer Eiskunstlauf
Übertragungen für SRF und er ist
Geschäftsführer der isaacademy zuvor
führten die beiden eine Fernbeziehung
manchmal einrichten mich in Japan in
China oder in Lyon zu treffen oder wir
machen Ferien in Südostasien
das war eine sehr glückliche Zeit in
meinem Leben
alles war gut ich hatte damals zwar am
anderen Ende der Welt aber wir waren uns
sehr nah
kein Porsche
dann fertig
nach zwei Jahren zogen sie in Montreal
zusammen
[Musik]
war sie in meinem Herzen für immer
Monika und Eva haben einen gemeinsamen
Traum auf diesem Reisfeld soll eine
Plantage für naturheilkräuter entstehen
bis es soweit ist überlassen Sie die
2.300 Quadratmeter den Bauern als
Leihgabe
alles ist grün wir sind wir
ja
so gesehen
noch ist das Projekt erst eine Idee aber
die war hat schon viel Vorwissen
ist
[Musik]
gut für die äußerliche Anwendung beim
Bauch
den beiden schwebt ein Zentrum für
ganzheitliche Gesundheit vor
das hier ist Pakis man kann es als
Gemüse essen
meine Familie gab mir ihr Wissen früh
weiter sie arbeitete auf dem Reisfeld
und mein Großvater erklärte mir alles
Wissen weitergeben und gleichzeitig ein
gemeinsames Business aufbauen noch ist
das erst eine Vision
[Gelächter]
auf dem Markt gingen sagte ein älterer
Schwede zu uns wieso in aller Welt
liegst du den langen Weg in die Schweiz
zurück um eine Frau zu finden Schweden
ist doch voll von ihnen
ich hatte keine gute Antwort es
passierte einfach
[Gelächter]
die ist schwer
Wiedersehen mit Florence und Niklas wie
bringen hin und weg hat sie während
ihrer dreijährigen Fernbeziehung
begleitet heute beginnt für das Ehepaar
ein neuer Lebensabschnitt
du hast viel zu viel Krempel
aber du bist mein Held du schaffst das
ja und ich bin auch ein Zauberer ich
verdopple den Stauraum ja dein Name ist
Niklas Copperfield
[Gelächter]
Florence zieht zum Niklas nach Schweden
ihr Wunsch geht in Erfüllung
[Gelächter]
okay es gibt doch Waschpulver in
Schweden
sondern auch für Hunde neun Stück müssen
mit ich reise zum ersten Mal mit 300
Hunden
die 51-Jährige ist passionierte
Tierschützerin alle ihre Hunde hat sie
aus erbärmlichen Umständen gerettet
Cockpit mitfahren
vor drei Jahren
also es ist schon
ja ganz anders also
Heims muss ihre beiden Töchter in der
Schweiz zurücklassen die jüngere wohnte
bis vor kurzem noch zu Hause
der Abschied von neuer fällt schwer sie
brauchte besonders viel Zuwendung
schön dich zu sehen wir haben noch
Werkzeuge für dich
du bist jetzt auf dich allein gestellt
es hat Verlängerungskabel Zubehör
ein Hammer alles mögliche
neuer hatte psychische Probleme mit
Angststörungen und Panikattacken
künftig wird sich die Großmutter um sie
kümmern
hast du was gegessen nein
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
wir sind bei dir am Telefon und im
Herzen
machen wir weiter
[Musik]
weil neuer Flugangst hat befürchtet
Florence eine längere Trennung
du bist okay sein sie auch
sie ist schon groß
alles andere ist okay aber sie
zurückzulassen tut am meisten weh
1 2 3 4 5
mit etwas Glück haben wir alle
ja das ist immer
das war halt einmal Emotionen
Autopilot ein klappen ausgefahren los
geht's
[Musik]
1600 Kilometer liegen zwischen
Derendingen und ihrem neuen Leben in
Schweden
[Musik]
Ehemann und Ehemann
und Ehefrau hat etwas Offizielles
verbindlich und eine zusätzliche
Bekräftigung
[Musik]
vor sechs Jahren haben sich Jamal und
Roma das Jawort gegeben
[Musik]
wie jung du warst
das war noch früh am Abend erinnerst du
dich ich habe dich noch nicht gefragt du
hast noch nicht mit dem Schlimmsten
gerechnet 2016
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
es war Dezember ich war bei meiner
Familie in Lyon in Frankreich Jamal war
in der Schweiz über Weihnachten wir
haben nicht zusammen gefeiert ich kam
später noch wir hatten Krieg wir hatten
eine kleine Auseinandersetzung weil ich
nicht rechtzeitig zugesagt hatte ich
hatte schlecht geplant
damals war ich noch nicht so
schweizerisch
auf der Suche nach einem
Weihnachtsgeschenk ich war unterwegs
dachte das habe ich ihn schon gekauft
eine Tasche hat er schon und ich kam an
einer biotrie vorbei und ich dachte
Schmuck wieso nicht und einfach so wieso
nicht einen Ring und einen Heiratsantrag
hatte
ein halbes Jahr später läuteten in
Montreal die Hochzeitsglocken
bei diesem Standesamt
aber hier jetzt Haut wie beim Flughafen
sein
im Gebäude und mir sie auch irgendwie
gestanden
[Musik]
nee das schaffen
ich liebe solche Missgeschicke
und ja beim Ehe Gelübde wurden die Gäste
emotional der Tod deine Mutter machte
wir sind nicht die super Romantiker aber
es war schon emotional
das lustigste war
nach der Trauung mussten wir den Ausgang
links nehmen
nichts war angeschrieben Scheidung
falls es nicht funktioniert
[Musik]
Florence Niklas und die neuen hunde sind
in Südschweden angekommen nach 30
Stunden
[Musik]
es fühlt sich wie Ferien an die Nacht
zwei Wochen vorbei sind
mit dem Unterschied dass wir viele Hunde
und viele Kisten dabei haben
wirklich merkwürdig
ist es sehr gut gegangen
oh Achtung
ihr Haus liegt mitten im Wald Niklas hat
es eigenhändig für sie gebaut
florents sieht es zum ersten Mal in
fertigen Zustand
oh mein Gott
Henry
willkommen zu hause
[Musik]
oh mein Gott
danke dir
vor fünf Jahren haben sich die beiden
auf Facebook kennengelernt die Pandemie
verzögerte das zusammenziehen
bis jetzt immer noch gesehen
wunderschön wir sind noch nicht fertig
aber ist mir egal den Rest machen wir
zusammen es war ein super Projekt ein
langes Projekt
[Gelächter]
verbindlich und sicher
vor eineinhalb Jahren zogen Jamal
Uthmann und Roma Adenauer in eine
großzügige Wohnung im ehemaligen
Industriequartier Montreals
das passt
alles auspacken ja klar
bald werden die beiden mehr Platz
brauchen darum wollen sie das
Gästezimmer umfunktionieren
ich führe nur aus er liest die
Gebrauchsanweisung die mir dies gib mir
das damals
[Musik]
in wenigen Wochen wird ihr Leben
komplett auf den Kopf gestellt
eine große Veränderung in unserem Leben
das Projekt haben mir vor vier Jahren
begonnen jetzt will das konkret wir
werden Eltern
zwei Väter unser BB wird in fünf sechs
Wochen geboren werden
[Gelächter]
am Anfang unserer Beziehung hat mir
Jamal gesagt er wollte immer schon ein
Kind
ich auch aber ich sehe keine Möglichkeit
aber dann haben wir realisiert hier in
Kanada ist es für uns legal ein Kind zu
kriegen
uns hat überzeugt dass es hier möglich
ist ein Kind großzuziehen
ich war noch etwas zurückhaltend
[Musik]
auf Bali ist der Markt für Koch Deva ein
Schlaraffenland
zum kleinen Chili
Monika und die war haben vor elf Jahren
geheiratet weil auf Bali nur Paare mit
demselben Glauben getraut werden
konvertierte Monika zum Hinduismus
seitdem sind Opfergaben für die Götter
Teil des täglichen Gebets
sie schaut wirklich
zu Hause ist die Küche Devas Reich hier
ist er im Element
meine Mutter war die beste Köchin auf
Bali
aber leider habe ich sie nicht richtig
gekannt sie ist sehr früh gestorben
glaube ich dass sie und die Götter mich
inspirieren
als das Paar nach acht Jahren Bali in
die Schweiz zog machte Deva eine
tellerwäschekarriere
ich arbeitete als küchengehilfe
überall mit
so bin ich aufgestiegen
Monika war damals als marketing-fachfrau
tätig weil sie und die war auf Bali ein
Gesundheitsprojekt umsetzen wollen
suchte sie nach Investoren
arbeitete in verschiedenen Hotels
schließlich kochte er für ein
renommiertes Restaurant in Zürich
in der das war in der Küche des Club
poolack
[Musik]
in den ich mache das misonplatz hier für
eine Ente
ja ihr könnt mir das geben ich kann
helfen
er sagte ich unterstütze Dich
ich war so glücklich und dankte den
Göttern
zurück nach Bali beide vermissten die
Wärme und die balinesische Lebensart
hier können Sie ein gutes Leben führen
Unterstützung
nehmen also da müsste man einfach viel
danke
[Musik]
aber jetzt ist es stärker als zuvor je
besser wir uns kennenlernen und je mehr
Zeit wir zusammen verbringen
erst vor wenigen Stunden sind Florence
und Niklas in Schweden angekommen nach
einer kurzen Nacht richten Sie Ihr neues
gemeinsames zu Hause ein
gute gut
weiter
so ich bringe die schlafzimmerpaneele
ins Schlafzimmer
da sollen sie ja auch hin okay
ich schaffe das
[Gelächter]
noch ist die Nähe ungewohnt
ich versuche mich von der
Inneneinrichtung fernzuhalten
sie macht die Pläne und sie ändert sie
auch
[Gelächter]
keine Beschwerden nein
Niklas kann sich draußen verwirklichen
habt ihr in der Schweiz diese alten
Wasserpumpen
[Musik]
perfekt oder der Hausbau zog sich hin
Niklas der einen Handwerksbetrieb führt
machte fast alles selbst Freunde halfen
ihm
ich glaube ich habe meine Freunde noch
ja ich verbrachte sehr viele Stunden
hier
an die 2000 vielleicht
ist
gleichzeitig arbeitete ich in meiner
Firma Montag bis Freitag 7 Uhr morgens
Traum seit ich 20 war wollte ich meinen
eigenes Haus bauen
das ist das Beste was ich je gemacht
habe
du machst das gut
schön da zu sitzen und mir beim Arbeiten
zuzusehen
[Gelächter]
wir brauchen eine Pause
bald sind die Gedanken wieder bei
Tochter neuer die in der Schweiz
geblieben ist
und man fühlt sich sehr schuldig
wir können Sie auch von hier aus gut
unterstützen
du kannst jeden Tag mit dir sprechen
per Flugzeug bist du in zwei Stunden bei
ihr
ist
Erwachsenenleben sie muss jetzt auf sich
selbst aufpassen
für seine große Liebe hält der
50-Jährige noch eine ganz besondere
Überraschung bereit
wie cool ist das denn das ist für uns
ein Privatstrand
einen eigenen Strand
das ist unser kleines Paradies
[Musik]
hier benutzen dürfe
in der nächsten Folge von hin und weg
können Jamal und Roma die Ankunft des
leihmutterbabys kaum erwarten
bei der Familie seines Bruders kann sich
Jamal auf die neue Rolle vorbereiten
in Schweden wird Niklas zum
medizinischen Notfall
sie haben mich not operiert
Monika gediegene Inneneinrichtungen für
den internationalen Markt
hin du Deva will mit dem Tempeltanz den
Göttern eine Freude bereiten
du musst dich mit den Göttern verbinden
dann geht es wie von selbst wie eine
Meditation
[Musik]